- You say, "Ew"?
Who say, "Ew"?
This is really good.
(rock music)
- I've never had dulce de leche before,
but I did take three years of Spanish
so I can guess that this
is some sort of combination
of milk and sugar.
- Of course I love dulce de leche.
I'm latino as fuck.
- This is caramel.
What is it?
This is dulce de leche?
This?
- I'm guessing this is
flan with dulce de leche?
Oh my God.
- It's almost like sinful peanut butter.
It has the texture of peanut butter,
but I feel terrible about
myself when I eat it.
- I don't like this part,
but this part is great.
The actual dulce de leche, that's amazing.
- It doesn't scream in your mouth,
"Oh my God, I'm sweet!"
It's mostly like, "Hey, girl,
I'm gonna hug your tastebuds."
- It's like putting the
two best things together.
It's like if Biggie and
Tupac made a song together.
(rock music)
- Guess it.
- I don't know what to think about this,
but I want it in my mouth.
- Oh my God.
- Oh. My. God.
This is the best thing ever.
I'm not ever being extra.
- So good.
It's like flaky, and
again sugary and sweet,
but like not too sweet.
- I didn't want to try
this other thing because
I'm really into this.
- The dulce de leche is
sandwiched between two cookies.
Then it's like drenched
in chocolate or meringue,
like what more do you want in your life?
- These look like little Oreos.
Oreo plus this dulce de leche stuff,
like I'll never eat Oreos again.
- What is inside of it?
So caramel.
Okay, just kidding, Argentinians.
- This one's a little more chewy,
kind of like eating a Snickers, I imagine.
I'm allergic to nuts,
so I don't really know
what that's like.
- It's honestly like eating
an amazing chocolaty,
dulce de leche cloud.
- It's like an amped up Girl Scout cookie.
- Okay, this is love.
Who need relationships?
- I've had kind of like
the Mexican version
of dulce de leche, but I've
never had it combined with
this Argentinian spin.
- Dulce de leche on
everything is a genius idea.
I can't believe they had this in Argentina
and I never tasted it.
(rock music)